Hello 晚上好，欢迎来到环兴聊天室的环兴聊天室的环兴电台的专访栏目啊。
上一次我们专访的嘉宾是大门幼，应该还有一些印象吧，已经过了很久了。
对，我们的直播依然是以低频的速度在持续，但我觉得持续可能会比它断了更重要吧。
只要是它有持续，它不会断掉，我觉得这个事就不会没了。
然后我们今天要专访的一个嘉宾叫去罗马。
我觉得环兴地的元老用户啊，或者说比较经常玩的人，一点都不会陌生这个名字，以及不会陌生他的作品。
因为他的名字很特别，他的作品也很特别。
至于怎么个特别呢？你可以在环兴地的公众号看到我们对他进行的一个文字稿的采访。
当然今天能来到直播间的也可以听到他的声音，跟他可以更深入的去了解到他的一些创作的想法。
以及我们即将要讨论的一些可能更深入的一些想法。
OK，那我们就现在连线去罗马。
Hello，晚上好。
晚上OK。
哎呀，真的是，你是24年，紧张吗？
有一点，因为之前有接受过这种类型的采访吗？
没有，没有，是第一次。
因为我，我本来就是，我本来就是挺摄控的，对对对。
然后因为，因为，因为你对我来说是一个，就是技术系统。
对对对，我知道。
反正我都这么说。
对，好，因为，因为感觉就是这样子重型，是第一次好像就是，就是这样子好像跨越了屏幕的那种感觉，就是觉得有点奇妙。
我刚刚有看到，就我刚刚开播的时候，你就好像没几分钟，你进来了一下。
对对，我就先感受一下，不分为。
提前熟悉，提前熟悉。
因为真的就是第一次以这种形式，然后，其实你之前跟我说要跟我连线的时候，我一开始还。
想拒绝，我知道。
对对对，因为，因为我我还挺怕我会落气之类的，然后我怕我表达不好，
或者表达不准确，然后。
但其实有的时候是需要接受一些。
其实也还好。
对对对，他本身他不是。
他不是要要去上北大，对不对。
那他就是一个，他就是一次非常有趣的谈话，也没有什么。
对吧，特别高声的那些词，词招要要去表述了的，没必要。
是。
你好像是24年，24年什么时候大概什么时候进。
24年5月份吧，5月份还是6月份。
刚好才一年多，然后两年了，两年多了。
对。
哇，就是我，我有一点我特别感动的地方，就是。
就是虽然说环境地，我这个要说实话，就是虽然说环境地有5现在5700多个人啊。
大家应该都就是经常玩的人，应该都都有意识的啊，就是真正。
还时不时能上来发发照片的人，其实真的很少，这个是我我非常能理解的，
因为大部分还是在看嘛，或者甚至大部分人加入了以后，其实就把这个事忘了。
这也是这也是这可能是绝大部分，就是他们可能就把这个事忘了，
他就是只是偶尔在朋友圈里面看到我发一些照片，这样子。
然后这个事就就忘了，就是他也不会说，那话余期了，就像余期了，
我会主动去联系，对吧，这个其实是很大一部分人都是这样子的。
所以像你这样，哎，他持续的还依然在，就像我上次采访大门幼一样，
就他有一个持续的，这样的持续是非常让我觉得。
就是我做这个事啊，特有成就感的一个地方，就是哎，这波人。
他还是能在能愿意继续在这里面去分享自己，去展示自己的，
这个就挺挺挺好，真的很很好。
就是我现在就是一个积累的一个过程，我要积累越来越多的这样的人，
当然可能再过个一年，大家都会因为各自的生活的变故，
然后甚至可能会有一些方向上的转变，
那就可能就真的就会有人消失，就会有人在你的这个世界里面消失，
这太多了，我做了十六年，这个太经历了太多这样的人了，
但是我觉得，哎，这一年或说这两年前，这两年时间的里面，
依然能够是不是看到这个人，这个是我特别真实的一个事情，
特别是像你这种表达力还特么特别强的人。
因为我的视角其实也是这样，因为经常就是就算我没有拍照的时候，
我也会在朋友圈看到你分享的那些，
这其实就是觉得是相互陪伴的这种感觉。
我为什么发朋友圈，也是出于这样的一个原因，
就是我觉得虽然说也有一些人不看朋友圈，
但是即便你不玩社交平台，也不去弄那个繁琐的知识星球，
但是你可能偶尔打开朋友圈的时候，
你会看到我在那里发了一张让你可能今天心情好的一张照片，
这就够了，我就觉得这就够了。
我觉得很了不起，
没有没有一点都不了，因为一点都没有什么了不起到这种程度，
就是我是觉得为什么我会觉得这样的事情对我来说是有满足感的，
是因为我在这个过程中我也有一种被看到的一种状态，
就是我们每个人做任何事情哪怕你发小无数都是为了被看到，
这个是非常基本的一个对啊，非常基本的一个需求，
人人皆是没有一个人能够做到完全说我那除非你去隐居那隐居的那种人，
这就非常少嘛，前面先感慨一下，
然后我们就直接进入正题吧，
我觉得我每次采访我都会让这个摄影师表述一下他怎么开始摄影这个事情，
我觉得我们今天可以不需要那个，
因为你其实在采访文字采访里面，
我觉得已经说得比较详细了，也比较清楚了，
所以我们今天包括我今天我刚才直播前我有说过，
我做了一个很长的笔记，
梳理了很多的因为你的作品而产生的一些问题，
所以我们就展开这个问题就可以开始，
我们先来到第一部分，
就是说你其实在第一个问题里面，
也就是说你什么时候开始摄影的一个里面，
你提到了一个你说就是摄影，
就是像命运一样交到人人的手里，
这个命运说很多人都会用命运说，
包括我自己也经常会说命运，
命运让我做了这个图片编辑，
然后好像就是不是你主动选择了摄影，
好像就是说是命运交给了你，
那我想问对，我想问就是说，
如果没有摄影，你觉得你现在在做什么，
或者说你现在是什么样子的一个状态，
那我觉得如果没有摄影的话，
我可能会做音乐吧，
倒是也相同，
因为我很喜欢音乐，
所以你现在可能只是画了一个形式，
所以你现在除了摄影，
其实音乐这个事情也在渐行吗，
没有,
但是我其实还蛮想，
特别是尤其是今年，
我有一个十几年的好朋友，
他就是叫伊宁，
他是一个超级大帅哥，
然后我拍过他很多照片，
然后他就是玩摄影完了十二年，
后来出了一本书，
出完这本书以后，
他就不拍照了，
也不能说完全不拍，
去做乐队去了，
他是吉他手，
对，他就现在就去做吉他手，
所以我觉得这个事也不矛盾，
就是说如果你觉得没有摄影，
当时没遇到摄影，
你肯定去做音乐，
我觉得这个事情，
即便你遇到摄影了，
也可以去做，
只不过你可能说的是，
你可能会更深入的，
比如我就是去学一门乐器，
或者说去学乐礼的东西，
然后去真正的去深入到那个礼去学，
所以我觉得也不矛盾，
即便是现在重新去学也可以，
当然也可以作为一个存心上，
我觉得你丢你这次直播，
这专访的那个推荐的音乐就非常好听，
对，就能看出来，
我觉得他很满足，
因为我觉得这两种，
就是两种不同的方式，
他其实最终的目的，
对我来说他的目的就是表达，
我觉得是一样的，
对,
你看我们很多人都会说，
摄影改变了我，
摄影因为摄影的出现，
好像我的人生变得不太一样，
或者是，
当然这种话我说的最多，
你觉得他是改变了什么，
你觉得他改变的是能力呢，
还是说，
更大的说是一种人格，
我觉得最大改变应该就是，
好像我可以被别人看到，
因为我觉得就是在接触，
特别是加入环形地的那个节点，
在那之前的话，
我会觉得自己就是，
比较怎么说，
就是没有被看到的一种感觉，
但是这种看到本身是不是，
我觉得是不是，
更像是一种，
通过摄影而，
先看到自己，
这么说是不是更顺这个事，
就因为你看到自己的，
自己潜长的一些，
一些信息，
然后这些信息，
你才希望被别人，
同样感受到，
是不是这样一个过程，
所以摄影对我们的改变，
可能更多的是，
先从自己，
我觉得，
让自己变得，
我之前跟很多人说过，
我在20岁，
因为我大概是，
18、19岁的时候，
喜欢摄影嘛，
然后我就说，
然后大概在20岁左右的时候，
网络社区这个平台，
然后当时就认识了很多人，
就感觉自己，
前面20年白活了，
而且我一直在说，
好像我前面20年的记忆，
是非常非常模糊的，
就即便是20岁以前，
好像那些记忆，
它都不属于我，
只有我在玩摄影以后，
我的记忆才属于我，
所以这个是一个，
蛮有意思的一个过程，
因为它对我的，
摄影对我的记忆是非常非常非常大，
不过你刚才这样形容，
我有会有这种感觉，
但是我可能我的时间跟你不一样，
我会有一种，
大学四年有点白活的这种感觉，
那相同啊，
类型，对，
会有这种感觉，
因为我大学四年，
我的状态就是完全是那种，
就是无所事事，
就是完全不知道自己在干嘛的那种，
就是这种感觉，
然后后来，
其实你高中就开始，
当然那时候还是完全不知道，
摄影这个东西，
对对对，那时候只是有，
有一台相机，
但是我也没有去倒过它，
什么的其类的，
大学可能，
开始有，就是有把它打开，
然后去拍了一张照片，
这样子，
这个很有趣，
可能,
突然有一天，
开始意识到，
摄影做的东西，
它可以如此的放大，
你自己的表达的过程，
这个,
就是从，
就是那个出门的世界，
它后来发现了那个，
然后推开那个门的那个状态，
很像,
所以还是命运吧，
我觉得就是，
对，所以就，
很多时候摄影它会，
它会,
它甚至，我在想，
它是不是帮我们开了一个，
就是第三只眼，
就是有的时候我们，
可能两只眼看到的东西，
并不是，
摄影所看到的东西，
就是摄影，
摄影真正看到的东西，
一定不是我们，
正常人两只眼睛看到的，
开了一个新的维度，
而我们第二部分，
就是我想聊到，
你说的这个黑白，
因为我觉得，你的黑白拍的，
那我真的超喜欢，
我一直，包括我有段时间，
就是我今年年，上半年的时候，
一直在放黑白的照片，
因为我，我有这样的一个，
周期性的一个问题，
就是我有的时候，
特别就是，
不太愿意用摄影表达的时候，
用黑白，
就是我觉得，
只有在黑白，
黑白是我的一种，
找回的一种方式，
它很能帮我，
把我这段的，
时间的这种，不愿意表达的情绪，
突然又放大起来，
我想问一下，
是吧，你也有一点，是吧？
我有一点，
你看，你的黑白，
其实，早期的时候，
你才的限制，
就是说，你当时，
对吧，也是因为，
练习卷，别人的那个练习卷，
然后发霉了，
就是别人不要的，
对，你有没有想过，
就是，如果当时，
那个人没送你，
你觉得你现在，
会不会变成另外一种摄影师？
我觉得，
会不会？
我觉得会吧，
对，他确实是把那个卷给我，
然后我也确实就是，
用那个卷拍，
对，我记得当，因为当时，
好像，那时候，
因为我那时候在张州，
张州其实，那时候，那时候是下雨，
然后很湿，
我们那时候那个出租，
就是很夸张，
就我们那个墙壁都开始发霉了，
然后，我又没有，我当时没有，
因为那时候还没有说，很，
很懂得要怎么保护器材之类的，
然后那时候，
我的相机就是随便放在，
放在某个角落，
然后那时候那个卷，
还有那个镜头都发霉了，
然后有一卷拍出来，
就是上面全都是美斑的，
但是我还觉得，
意外来还蛮好看的，
就是很多，其实这会影出来一个问题，
就是风格的问题嘛，
就是很多，包括我们，
《中国环境地》以后，
非常多的人问这个风格的问题，
我该怎么去选择我的风格，
我该怎么去通过，
学习,
去掌握一种风格，
但是，实际的情况是，
很多人的风格，
其实是来自什么，没钱，
我们买不起镜头，
对，买不起胶减，
甚至不会调涉，对吧，
或者他生活环境非常糟糕，
就这些东西，
反而成就了他的某种风格，
就比如你最开始的时候，
你根本没有这个条件，
买更好的，比如胶卷，
或者是器材，那如果你刚开始，
你的出生非常好，
你就是一个
家里面非常，
资金雄厚的一个家庭，
你刚开始就买了哈苏去拍照，
你现在一定会成为另外一个摄影师，
对吧，所以很多时候，
我们的风格是，
真的不是说，
我们选择来的，
就是很多时候，
这种现实的结果，
就你处在了一个现实的状态里面，
那你可能就会形成那样的风格，
或者说，
所以我觉得，
不是一个值得纠结的问题吧，
我觉得，
但是很多人，
这是一个，
可以理解的问题，
就是大部分的普通爱好者，
他处在这样的一个状态里面，
是非常可以理解的，
一个社会在教他，
就是,
整个社会在营造出来一种，
你应该学这种风格，
你应该学那种风格，对吧，
对，就会给他造成困扰，
有什么教片缝啊，
或者是，
所以像你这样的，
就是,
可能有一些歪打正招，
可能有一些什么命运的选择，
但是,
他反而，
定了一个风格，对吧，
那这个风格，
可能就会一直追随着你，
所以很多时候，
很多所谓的经典的风格，
都是偶然，
就这个例子就太多了，
比如我在，
这个直播，
这不是那个采访里面，
我有跟你列举过那个，
《仙来苍酒》，对吧，
《仙来苍酒》拍那个乌鸦，
拍那个鸦，
不就是，
他拍的那么虚，对吧，
我觉得《仙来苍酒》这种，
或者说《深山大道》这种，
大家都已经非常非常熟了，
就是,
就是，你像他这种东西，
他真的是，
一种，就是，
纯选择嘛，就，
我觉得可能更多的还是，
因为他在那个状态下，
比如他拍夜晚的乌鸦，
他用再好的机器，
照片,
这个条件，
条件就是那么个条件，
你说他怎么拍到那么很实的照片呢，
他根本不可能拍到，
他拍到的就一定是虚的，
就一定是模糊的状态，
但是这种模糊的状态，
反而让他，
觉得，或者说，
他自己没有太觉得，
但是，可能他的粉丝会觉得，
真的，真的这种风格非常非常好，
非常非常，
偶然包括，
包括这个，
深山大道会弄了一些照片，
深山大道这种，大家就太熟乱，
真的很熟，很熟，
嗯,
所以很多情况，
也不是说主动选择吧，
其实就是没得选，
对，就是没得选，
真的就没得选，
你像深山大道这样的拍法，
他本身就是要素技的一个拍法，
就是,
拿再好的机器，
他一定要快速捕捉的时候，
再好的机器都没有用，
对他来说，
都没有用，所以他就用最简单的，
就用吉亚就可以嘛，
所以他为什么，成了吉亚代言人嘛，
呵呵,
你包括，
威廉·埃克斯顿这个彩色笔主，
彩色胶片的笔主，
他最早，
七零年代的时候，最早就是，
拍彩色脚卷嘛，那时候，
所以，就是用彩色，
大家都会认为，
摄影就是黑白的，黑白胶卷，
因为黑白胶卷很稳定，对吧，
那彩色的就是相对不稳定，
你从少有成本居高，
但是他就，
去做了这个事，
他就把这个事情，
这个红色的天花板，
这个，大家都很熟了，
嗯,
对，就，就，这真的很熟了，
这个，这些图，
这个彩色生意的革谜的嘛，
所以我觉得很多时候，
呃，风格这个东西，
真的不用，
说，那么的，
纠结，就是他有的时候，
是自然而然的发生的，
嗯,对,
所以你觉得自己的，自己，
有的人，有人是觉得自己，
不承认自己有风格，
你会觉得自己是有风格的吗？
我觉得如果，
从整体上来看，
还是有一点吧，有的吧，
嗯，其实，就是你，
你给我的发来的问题的时候，
你给我总结一些关键词，
我就觉得还描述的，
蛮精确的，
蛮确实就是这样，
但我觉得，大部分人看到你的照片，
都会想到那些关键词，
这，这是，这是风格，
带来的最直观的一种感受，
就是，刚才我举深山大道，
或者说，深来长走这种例子，
就他就是，他的照片，
就是最好的说明，
他不需要文字，
对吧，那你看到那些照片，
你就会感受到孤独，
感受到，感受到痛，
感受到一种，
迷茫，一种困国，
那这种东西，就是自然而然发出来的，
这个就是图像的魅力，
是啊，是啊，
所以其实，你看，
如果你当年，
你当年没有那台发霉的，
对焦用，如果你换了一个，
最好的机器，你可能，
今天就不是去罗马了，
你可能是，
你可能是去法国了，
去巴黎了，对吧，
就会，真的就会这样的，
有这样的转变，
因为我接触过很多很多人，
他就是，他最开始接触的，
就是，比如小金星，
那他可能后续的发展，
就会变成，
如果想要往商业的话，
去派20元，派20元，
对，然后他就是，
会这样子的线路去走下去，
当然也有一些意外的，
就是说，他在这个过程中，
他又接触到了一些新的东西，
然后又，
所以很多时候环境，
对我们的影响是非常的，
是第一，第一的，
对，环境影响是第一的，
所以我，
挺高兴，就是，
现在你是去罗马，
那里,
哎呀，所以，
很多时候，就是，
你像你，我们再回到，
你这个风格上面的问题，
就比如，
私交，比如这种模糊的处理，
一些,
混沌的影响，
其实，我们在想，
现在这个时代，
现在这个时代，就是，
我们所有的东西都在追求什么，
追求，就是，
或者说，越完美，
甚至,
AI的星期，
让我们，很多东西，
根本不需要我们自己去做，
它都可以产出，
非常清晰的，
完美的，
完美无瑕的一些内容，对吧，
那你觉得，
为什么现在，包括你，
会喜欢这种，
粗糙的，
可能跟这个时代，
并不契合的这些内容，
你为什么会选择？
我觉得，可能，
基本来，我，我觉得我自己，就是一个，
主流之外的人吧，
然后，我觉得，我自己也是一个，
其实，我现在有很多瑕疵，
然后，就是很不完美的地方，
也是有很多缺陷，
所以,
我有很自然的被，
这样的东西，所吸引，
就像一个，
就像一个苹果，
那它，也还是会有果营，
会想要去，
去吃它，
哎呀，这个形容太好了，
这个形容太好了，
这个冰沙，
对，就是这种感觉，
但是，很多时候，
呃,
你会想到这一层，
就是你会想到苹果烂了，
有果营，会吃它，
但是，可能大部分的人，
我相信大部分人，
就是因为他们，
意识到自己的不完美，
所以，他会在，
极力的把美颜开到底，
把那个脸拉得跟驴一样长，
就是,
他在演示他的这个，
本来可能是个方脸的，
这个现实，对吧，
所以，他极力的在演唱这个东西，
但并不代表，他不知道自己的缺点，
而，你能做到的，
就是说，你即便知道了这些缺点，
你还愿意，
释放的空间，比如你，
即便是一个烂的苹果，
它依然可以有，
有人，或者说有超硬去侵赖它，
有果营去侵赖它，
对，所以，这个是非常，
我觉得非常重要的一点，
那，那你觉得，就是说，
呃,
其实你这，
我不能说，类型啊，
就是说，
你喜欢的这方面的这些东西，
比如这些，
颗利感啊，这些模糊的状态，
呃,
它其实也是有一部分人，
很，很，比如我自己就很喜欢嘛，
所以，我在愿意去释放你，
你觉得，这样一部分人，
它是一种，
怎样的心理，它是一种，
反消费主义的心理嘛，
就是因为我们，其实，
为什么一定要，
呃，不要那么精美，
就是因为我们不想要那些，
消费主义带给我们的那些东西，
你觉得是有这样的，
这样的因素在的吗？
会有这样的部分吧，
但是，但是如果你，
你用这样的想法，
去想的话，你想的，
你要为了反消费去反消费，
那其实你还是，
还是还是在，
还是会被那个消费主义，
还是会陆绿那个陷阱，
我们说呢，就是有点，
你的意思就是有点说，
反抗主流，去非主流，
是这种感觉，
是不是有这种因素在？
我觉得，也有吧，
少不了，
少不了，这个东西少不了，
因为，对，少不了，
因为它其实是一个，
它并不是一个理性层面的，
它是一个感性层面的，
它是一个现实层面的一个问题，
就是我们其实现实世界，
就是这样子一个状态，
你想想，你想想，
这些东西，
所谓的精致，
你比如手机的这个，
手机的这个拍照的功能，
越来越强大，对不对？
然后,
它强大，它强大是在干嘛？
它其实是在告诉你，
你比如，
这种颜色才是正确的，
这样的肤色才是自然的，
或者说这样的天，
这样的天，这样的克莱英兰，
才是蓝，才是蓝天，
它其实是一套，
它是一套工业标准，
你会发现，
它就是一套非常工业化的一个标准，
就是让所有的人
都变成一样的，
一样的状态，
所以为什么我现在反过来，
我会说，我特别喜欢iPhone，
因为,
虽然说iPhone已经在做妥协了，
就是比如iPhone的相机，
它的这个，
它也在做眉眼了，
它还在守着一种，
相对真实的一种状态，
它并不会像安卓手机，
跟你加那么强的眉眼，
然后让你在拍照的时候，
其实那个东西，
是一个工业产品，
它根本不是你真实的你嘛，
是有这样的，
但是我觉得，
如果,
如果是在标准里面的话，
我会觉得，
你好像不需要做过什么努力，
你就可以去适应标准，
就比如说，
现在社会给你的标准，
就是,
就是结婚生孩子，
就是我妈给我的标准，
就是她说，
你要六岁之前，
你要去找一个男朋友，
然后你要结婚，
然后他就是已经把这个标准都列给你了，
然后你去回老家，
学校去当英语老师，
就他已经把这些录，
他都可以给你铺好了，
是的，那你还会想去走这条路吗？
其实就是，
那我肯定是不想的，
那我也不是说我是，
为了不结婚，
我也不是说为了不去那个，
做老师，不做老师，
就是我不想去走，
这条非常标准化的路吧，
是,
就是,
标准的，
所谓的标准答案都已经，
呃,
充斥着我们所有的生活了，
就是,
方方面面，
包括现在AI这么，
这么厉害，
其实AI它也是在制定一种标准，
但是,
我们其实，
为什么会，
还依然喜欢我们现在做的这种，
方式的影像，
其实是，
因为我们意识到，
现实从来没有，
标准的答案，
就是,
就是，你比如摄影嘛，
就是过度曝光，
呃，或者说，
你说的就，你说的你的，
色彩的颜色特别脏，
我觉得你这个脏这个字，
用的特好，真的，
就是我们，对，我们很多时候，
我们很多人，
都不知道，
脏这个字，
或者说，我们故意的，
磨掉脏这个字，
但是其实脏，
是，你在光线量里，
脏都存在的，
呃,
就是它，它没办法，
它没办法脱离，
因为脏就是一直在存在的，
然后，你像，
摄影里面，私交啊，
什么那种，什么，
真实的东西啊，它并不是，
你用S，AI，或者说，用相机，
用手机，现在的手机拍的那些东西，
才是真实的，那些东西，都是，
都是标准化的东西，它并不是，
我们真实的东西，
就是，我们现在的生活，
就是，越来越逃离这种真实，
所以我觉得，
可能,
你的影像的这个魅力，
就在于，让我们看到了这个脏，
让我们意识到了，
不完美的东西，
它也可以如此的，
打动人嘛，
你当时为什么会想到，
脏这个字，我很像，知道，
我不知道，就是，
文学表达，
就是在干脑，
跳出来，第一个字就是很脏，
因为我自己，就是，
处理那些彩的照片的时候，
我也是，其实我有时候，
也不是非常满意这些色彩，
它不是，总之，很取悦我的，
有时候是，我有时候也不是，
非常满意，但是，
好像最后也只能这样了，
我就会，有时候也会觉得我的色彩，
很乱啊，很脏啊，就那个，
没有这种感觉。
但是这种感觉，
其实不就是说明了，
它是真实的你的，
现状嘛，就比如，
你现在，你的确，
调不到那个，
你自己感到不脏的那种，
对，你现在，
没有到它那个程度，
那一张来，来，来，
来做办的一个过程，
所以反而它会，
让你的影像，会更真实，
它就是，会更大动人，
对吧?
对，对，我一开始，
一开始我在那个，
社美上发我自己的，
彩色，彩色照片的时候嘛，
就那段时间，我其实觉得我，
我调颜色真的好臭啊，
但是我发出去之后，
这样有人给我评论说，
我的调颜色很好看，
对，他这样说好看，
然后我当时，
我就是，我真的非常惶恐，
然后，这就像我以前说的，
就是好像一个苹果烂了，
但是还是会有，果银，
会盘旋在上面，
它会停留在上面，
对，我就是，
所以后来，我一开始，
有很焦虑自己，
就是我技术跟，
跟不上我的表达之类的，
我将会少很多，
是的，我觉得这个，
我们需要去意识到的东西，
就是，摄影这个东西，
它其实是一种，
非常能够，
让你意识到，
不完美的一个，
一个表达方式，
因为太多的人，
包括，我接触到很多，
玩儿教片的啊，
就它会有一个，
核心的一个诉求，
我拍数码，怎么拍，
颜色我都不满意，
所以它愿意用教片的那一套，
相对固定的，
这个,
这个标准化的东西，
对，因为教片还是有，
其实教片是有一些标准化，
只不过它的，
变化,
它的变化是有区间的，但是，
它的标准化是因为，
它的那种教片的那种颗粒感，
或者说那个饱和度，
数码，还目前，
还没办法达到的一个状态，
所以它其实在用数码的时候，
它就会很懵嘛，
就是我该怎么调啊，
调到我理想的那个，
所以很多人用教片，
真的是有一部分人用教片，
就是因为它不想调色，
对，就是有这样的诉求的，
但是也有一些玩教片，
特别厉害的，
就比如我前面说的那个朋友，
他就是自己把黑白的教片，
去除自己想要的样子，
就是这个过程，
比如它的那个冲扫的时候，
那个饱啊，厚啊，什么温度啊，
就这些东西，
它在这个里面寻找一些，
可能,
所谓的失败，或者说差词，
就是那些东西，
给它带来的那种，
感觉，就跟你在调数码，
数码作品的感觉是一样的，
你觉得那些照片是很脏的，
但是它其实，反而觉得，
就是发霉的矫卷，
对，就是这个道理嘛，
它就是觉得，
照片好像富裕了这个东西，
或者富裕了这种脏，
这个照片它就封影了，
评论期说，
就是怕，
自己来，自己有自己来认领的了，
所以,
我觉得，
我们其实应该要意识到这个问题，
它其实有点像，
打广告了，就是，
为什么我做环境地，
我其实是希望，
让很多摄影爱好者，
能够聚在这里，集中的看到一些，
就是,
就是那种失败的东西，
这个引号，
我觉得，
它可能不是失败的，
就可能对于这个作者来说，
它是失败的，
就包括你觉得，
你这张照片不好，
就不好的色彩，
它觉得最好，
很多时候，
我们应该把这些失败的东西，
放出来，
而不是一定要把一些东西，
美化过了，
呈现出来，
美化过呈现出来的东西，
一定是被人喜欢的，
但是就仅此而已，
结束了，
不会产生任何连结，
就是比如，
对吧,
排得不灵不灵，
都好看，
它就是只是在消费，
只是在看这个东西，
它不会让它产生任何连结，
对,
所以它就是，
我觉得，
很多时候，
环形地，
就是希望让大家放大这种，
失败的东西，
我们才能看到，
我们在这个世界上，
能够发生连结的一个重要的，
重要的，
信息吧，
聊到是不是有点深呢？
呵呵,
哎呀,
所以,
像我们今天这样的时代，
很多时候，
我老觉得自己好像有点，
粉丝技术，
这种感觉，
但是，不得不说，
所有的瑕疵都在被消除，
就是大的层面，
要求你正能量的，
小的层面，要求你，
要求你抹掉瑕疵，
把脸上的痘痘去掉，
但是,
真实的人生是这样的吗？
不是这样的，真实的人生，
就是充满了各种的，
各种的失败，
就每个人，其实都不傻，
每个人都意识到这些问题，
只不过，
我愿意去表达出来，
然后大家都在一个，
都在一个装的过程，
OK,我们,
真假的东西太多了，
是的，真的很多很多，
所以我，真的我看到，
我其实很早就想采访你了，
只不过，我需要，
我每次采访别人，
我需要他积累一些一定的发布量，
所以我老是跟别人说，
你要多更新还原地，
我才能，有更多的，
那我看到你更多的可能，
我就想要，
可以更深入的去了解，
所以我，你早期的时候，
因为你虽然说一直在更新，
但是你其实算更新社区里面，
跟那些更新的比较平凡的人还说，
还是相对比较不那么平凡，
但是作品量，
当然我觉得到了一定程度了，
我就觉得必须要去采访，
嗯,
我觉得我更新的还蛮少的，
是的，所以我就说嘛，
一定不多，但是，
我觉得到一定量的时候，
我都不会放过的，
就我十几年来，
一直变成的，
我不会放过任何一个，
我看上去就是，
我超爱的摄影师，
包括我上一期做那个，
大门诱的，
我觉得真的是，
就是他的照片，
就是能让我感觉到安静，
然后你的照片，
就是心跳，
就像我跑步一样，
就是跑到心欲飙升的那个状态，
就是,
所以我就想，
但是真的连接你，跟你聊天的时候，
你又是一个，
好像低沉，好像比较。
平稳的一个人，
所以这种反差就很有意思啊，
我觉得这是非常有意思的一个状态，
你现在是觉得我还挺低沉，
比较平稳，
还蛮稳的，
哈哈哈，
所以我呢，
你对我的评价呢，
就是,
我们上第一次联系，
我对你评价就是，
一直都觉得你是你的，
包容度非常高的，
谢谢,
我是不得不不高，
因为我觉得，
我这社区的话，
如果做得想爱了，
那是这个事，
应该要让更多的人，
意识到，
呃,
不仅是这个社区不狭隘，
对吧，你也可以不狭隘，
你也可以不要去，
偏执的理解一个社区，
哎，他就是那样子的，
比如很多，我，
刚开始直播的时候，我就说，
你去拉人嘛，
然后很多人就说，
啊，环境地的风格太安静了，
我不行，
我是拍街拍的，
我拍的都是那种街头，
那种随机的，
就是你真的没有去了解，
你已经把自己框住了，
对，他把自己框住，也怕我框住，
你就活在一个框框里，
就像你说的，
就是我们下面这个问题，
就是现成嘛，
对，就是你其实也提到了，
就是我们，
整个社会，
调调框框里活着，
就这样的一个现状嘛，
这样,
所以,
所以我们现在，
就是想聊聊这个现成，
我觉得，我为什么，
当时采访你的时候，
会想到用现成的这个，
因为我当时还，
特地，去小红书，
翻了班，他们那些拍现成的，
我真的觉得，
真的,
全是一个母子，
就是一模一样，
一个照片，
对，你一开始，我看到这个问题的时候，
我还蛮惊讶的，
就是因为，
因为我，我从来没有说，
把我的照片就是跟现成文学，
我说这个现成文学是，
最近这两年比较火的，
这个现成文学这个概念，
应该是24年，
24年左右火的，
当时那个抖音特别特别火，
因为我从来没有说，
就是想说要拍一组现成文学，
然后,
所以我当时就，
但是我后面又，
又往生了想，
我又觉得确实还是有点联系，
只是我没有说，
从那个现成文学那个概念出发，
说要去拍，
他有两个要素，
对上的，就是环境和人嘛，
因为他们那些，
拍那个现成文学，
然后环境也都是现成，
或者相正，
就这两个点对上了，
所以我就很难，
可能很难逃离这个，
所谓的第一印象吧，
嗯,
但是,
确实里面有些场景，
确实是在我老家里面拍的，
就是我老家就是一个现成文学，
对，所以其实我，
我个人觉得，
就像你说的，
其实他是被标签化的嘛，
但是其实现成文学，
他的一个核心理念，
其实是他换个地方，
他也成立，只不过，
现在被标签，
锁定到了一个现成的一个范围，
就是,
就是如果你换一个地方，
这个事他也是成立的，
因为他在表达的一个东西，
其实是一种，
嗯，停滞的状态，
就像我们停在了80年代，
就是一种停滞的状态，
一种身份感，
或者更悲哀的所，
是一种无力感，
我虽然说觉得，
大部分的人可能都会把他拍得。
積极向上，
拍得热情扬意，
什么那个，
改革开放那个，
那个着急蓬勃的那个状态，
就是把他，
会把他往那个方面去拍，
然后也有一些会拍的比较音域，
那个核心的一个，
他其实是一种，
我觉得在现在这个时代，
去讲这个东西，
其实是一种挺无力的感觉，
嗯,
好像,
我们在呈现一种积极向上的，
但是,
但是那些东西又是一个，
上个时代的东西，
好像这个时代，
完全脱节的一个状态，
就是这个时代的人在干嘛，
我觉得我们这个时代，
就是你好像很难去，
向往未来，你可能就只能，
往回看，否则，
所以现在也很流行，
复古,
所以说要回到，
这种千细年啊，
这种千细美学啊，
现在就是很流行这些人，
因为大家，
大家好像对未来，
没有什么，不抱什么期望了，
现在就是这样的状态，
要么看，
往身后看，
要么就是看现在，
反正就是这样一个状态，
其实，我想问，
你说你去年开始，
把镜头，
从别人转向了自己嘛，对吧，
就我很好奇，
这是一种，
主动的选择，
还是说，也是不得不要发生的事，
就是你不得不，
不这么去做，
就是整个社会的环境，
可能它给你的东西，
没办法让你得到什么了，
你可能也只能，
转向自己，
我觉得都有点吧，
因为去年，
去年算是一个转折点吧，
因为去年开始就是，
因为我那个采访稿也说了，
我说身体上开始，
开始出现一些变化，
因为我从，对，
去年开始就睡不好啊，
那种,
就很闷的那种感觉，
然后也可能去跟我工作有关吧，
因为我工作，
就要经常熬夜什么的，
然后那时候，
开始会有一点，
生存危机，
或者说，
好像有点开始虚无，
就是有点不知道，
好像有点不知道，
我现在干嘛，
我现在做这些意义是什么，
开始会想说，
把今后对着，
外面的世界对我来说，
好像有点没有意思，
我就想说，
想拍点自己的东西，
就是关于自我的东西，
但是这种自我的东西，
让我，其实让我想到一个事儿，
就是,
我们，因为你也说了，
你身体，你意识到一些身体的变化，
意识到自己的一个状态，
状态的一个，
就是什么，
就是我们，
经常会说，
艺术诞生于痛苦，
或者说，
会不会就是说，
并不是痛苦本身，
而是当下的这种，
现实没办法，
去容纳你的那种感受的时候，
你就不得不去选择，
另外一种，
表达的方式，
就是它可能并不一定是痛苦，
直接带来的转变，
而是，就像我们前面，
聊这个现成文学，
或者说，在当下的一个，
一个社会现状，
它本身已经没办法，
去容纳你对，
向外的一种表达，
所以你只能，向自己，
向自己来表达，
我觉得这是，一个普遍的现象，
包括我就环境地，
它其实也是一个向自己的，
就是慢慢走向一个，
更窄的可能，并不是一个，
特别,
往外界拓展的一个东西，
就是因为，
因为有时候，
这些痛苦你，
你，你不知道用什么东西，
去消化它们吗，
对,
虽然说，好像你拍出来，
好像也改变不了什么，
但是，只能说，
把它放在，放在一个，
是不是，
或者说，是不是一定要改变，
或者说，
我觉得其实，
也改变不了什么，
它也不会消失，
它就还是在那边，
它只是，
就是可能通过剩一个方式，
把它放在一个图像上，
或者,
对,
其实这个问题也是我，
就是我今年一直在想的问题，
我今年就是没怎么拍照了，
是,
就是有点停滞，
因为，就是，
嗯,
会有点不知道为什么要拍照，
有这种，
有这种感觉，
平静,
所以我大概有，
快半年没有拍照了，
嗯,
我上一次拍照还是那个，
就是,
对，已经过去好久了，
嗯,
我遇到太多了，
真的，我每天都，都接触到，
就是说，他会跟我说，
比如我半年没有拍照，
或者我好几年都没有拍照，
就是这样一波的朋友，
但是我，
通常会回答，我就说，
为什么一定要拍照，
就,就,
就不拍呗，就，反正，
是吧，但是他们又表现出来，
一种，啊，我不拍照了，
我好像失去了什么，
或者说，我好像没了表达，
但是我觉得，
并不是，
就是拍照这个事，
他可以一辈子等着你，
对，对，他可以一辈子等着你，
但是表达这个事，
并不一定是，
拍照，就，
唯一，就是唯一的，
就是你可以做任何事情，来，来，
把你的表达释放，
甚至我们今天连线这种方式，
也是一种表达的释放，
或者说他是一种，可能比摄影，
还更强的表达的释放，
所以拍照本身，他没那么重要，
他拍照，
永远都没那么重要，
包括，像我们，你，你，你，
你其实在，我们聊这个县城的时候，
我们会，
聊到这个，县城的，
地域的问题嘛，就是说，为什么，
你会喜欢，你不喜欢城市吧，
你为什么会喜欢，
去那些自然的地方，
或者说去，人少的地方，
就是因为，去到那里，
我就有表达了，
包括摄影师，
就，真的是去拍照的那拨人，
大家都知道，就是，
摄影师最爱去的地方，废墟，
工地,
什么，什么，铁路，对吧，
还有那什么，
什么，文字，到处都是文字的，
和比二是吧，就，他一定是去那些，
就是因为，
不，不仅是我去，不去到那里，
还是，去到那里，
就是一种表达，
对吧，这个，
我觉得这种就很重要，
而且,
我觉得很大一个原因，
就是我们去到那样的地方，
就像你其实也提到，
那个地方，他就没有了。
那些条条框框，
就你，当你，
当你站在一个，
一摊废墟之上的时候，
你没有了身份，你没有了，
规则,
没有了一些，
标准化的东西，
你随时，你可能，
如果旁边没人，你就，你就，
你就蹲那儿，就尿了一旁尿，
对，他，他是没有规则的一个世界，
所以这种没有规则，
本身可能，也是我们。
上面所聊的，他是一种，
打的方式，对吧，
所以真的，你不用。
太在意自己这个，
好像多久没有拍照这个事情，
我觉得，
他并不，他并不代表什么，
就是，拍照，
只是一种方式，
我们通向自由的地方，
不仅只有拍照，
呵呵,
还是,
生活更重要吧，就是，
是,是,
生活更重要，有的时候，
呃,
我可能要反过来的时候，就是，
痛苦也重要，就像，
你其实意识到自己的，
呃，身体出现了状况，
你意识到自己的情绪出现了状况，
嗯,
就是,
当然他不是，
他不是一定是痛苦，
直接产生的结果，
但是，你痛苦，
你痛苦了，或者说你痛苦以后了，
想去表达的，
你不表达你，
你这个痛苦就会，
就会记忆啊，对，他就会，
把你毁了，对，
就有点像，
你被人可能打了一层，
可能就是会整不成叫一下吧，
对呀，你得叫一下呀，
你或者说，
性情更高呢，
你要去还手啊，
所以很多时候，
你不能只挨打吧，
这位大环境就是还蛮，
控制我的，就是你可能，
你可能痛苦，但是，
如果你太过度的表达，
你可能还是，
还是会被批判，
那太多了，那太多了，
对，真的就是，
嗯，痛苦有点，
是不被允许的吧，现在，
对呀，要求，要求正能量嘛，
呵呵,
但是,
但是他其实是一个，
陷阱,
而且我相信，
很多人都知道他是个陷阱，
但是,
很多人，
一定要，
闭着眼睛往里跳，
就是他一定，
因为他没的，
社会给他的一个，
标准化的东西，
他没得选嘛，
然后我觉得最起码，
我们比较幸运的一点是，
像你释放到我们观察的世界里，
对，所以他，
本身就已经很足够了，
但是你如果，
想要,
啊，我半年没拍照了，
好像，啊，我没有去榨取他，
呵呵,
就，好像觉得我亏了，
对吧，这个，没必要，
真的没必要，就是，
表达可以随时，随时进行，
嗯,
OK,我们,
来聊到我们最合心的一个点，
呵呵,
最合心，最合心，
也是我，也是我可能，
最合心想要，当时，
想要采访你的一个点，就是，
呃，马齿，
我的模特，
对，就是你的模特，
真的，他，
我能想象到你在高中的时候，
遇见他的时候，那种，
第一眼的那个状态，
因为我从你的照片里面，
你能感受到，一种，那种，
第一眼被戳那样，
我是，大学的时候，
大学的时候，
我那种，
就是，就是我最早看他的时候，
我觉得他不是中国人，
会这样，
对，他不像中国人，
你，你会觉得吗？
他是，他是广西人，
不会啊，我觉得他还挺。
中国人的，
我可能觉得，我，我，
我跟你说，我最早，
第一印象，我觉得他日本人，
啊,
对，我，我，我一直，我甚至，
第一次，
我知道，他，他，
经常有人会说，他长得像那个，
那个谁啊，
立山千鸣，
立山千鸣，我还不知道，
对，那个演员，
就是他，他很，他很像日本人，
他很像日本人的面孔，
有关比较突出，
然后,
反正就是透着一种，
日本人的那种气质，
那种气质很，很，
很抓人，真的很抓人，
我觉得这个，
就让我第一印象就，就埋下了吧，
就是，我，我跟你说，
我甚至半年，
大概半年到，甚至一年的时间，
就你刚开始来的那半年，
或一年的时间，
我以为，他就是你，
对，我以为，你自在自拍，
其实很多人都，都以为，
是我的自拍，
对吧，对吧，那，那就是了，
然后，直到后面，
马此来加入了的时候，
我看了他的朋友圈，
我有点懵，
你知道吗，我当时在想，
诶，我说，诶，
他怎么发那么多你的照片，
然后，我在你的那个照片，
你的朋友圈里面，又，又有很多你，
他的照片，就，
我看是出现一个，
混乱的一个状态，
但是我后来，诶，慢慢的，
理解了，嗯，
经常有人会分不清我们俩，
就你们俩现实生活中，
本身也是很像嘛，
就我，我，我，
虽然说你给我那个合影，
不是，特别能看到你的正面，
但是我也是觉得蛮像，
是吧，对，
很多人说我们长得很像，
在那个，楼下的时候，
就有个阿姨说我们两个，
是不是亲姐妹，
诶，这个真的，很有缘，很有缘，
其实我，
当时，在这个，
采访里面，我有引用了这个，
Mius这个，这个，
词啊,
他其实并不是一个，
可能不是你理解的那个词，
那个意思，因为Mius他在，
他最早，他其实是希腊的一个，
灵感女神嘛，这个，
艺术和灵感的女神，对，
他其实是，代表了一种，
他给予创作者灵感的一个人，
就他是，
他本身，他在强调的一个，
其实就是，一种启发，
一种，陪伴，或者说，
共同成长的一个关系，
所以他最早，他的，他的寓意。
就是那样子的，那，
我举那两个例子，也是，
也是觉得就是说，诶，的确，
杨子，对这个，
荒木，或者说那个杨子，对，
深爱苍酒，他产生了这种，
灵感的一种来源，
甚至我看到你拍麻子，我也觉得，
诶，你的灵感，
应该是源于他的，
他的一种，不管是外在的，
或者说内在的一种，一种表述，
一种一种，一种呈现嘛，对，
所以，所以我，
我当时是，想到了，
就直接就想到了Mius这个词，
我觉得是，
我自己觉得是非常，
那个衣服，但是后来这个Mius他会，
当然我们马上会聊，
就是说他在摄影的这个，
里面，确实，
是有存在于你说的那个问题的，
就是说，摄影师，
摄影师他是拥有镜头的人，
所以摄影师，
在这个时代是拥有，
叙述权的一个，
一个人，
所以我们记住，
很多摄影师，
很多知名的摄影师，
但是，我们很少，
能够记住照片里面的那个人，
那个模特，他怎么看待自己，
几乎没有，
所以你的这个引述，
包括你后来引用了这个，
杨子的这些话，
真的非常非常，
就把我们这个问题，
在摄影里面，
所暴露的一个真相，
就是,
摄影其实，
它是一种权力的游戏，
它是一种真正的权力游戏，
对，因为摄影师，
他只拿着相机的那一刻，
他要去拍那模特的时候，
其实权力就已经，
不太对等了，
对，他就已经发生了转移，
因为被拍的人，他是，
对，被拍的人，
他到底暴露自己的一个过程，
他几乎是我自己，
对，他几乎是丢掉了人格，
我不知道，
我不知道这个，
就是我们直播间里面的人，
有没有了解过生态长久拍他妻子，
这个这本册子，
就是叫做无题的这本册子，
他其实就是拍他妻子，上班，
上班的时候，
的一个状态嘛，
但是他妻子，
其实你说的这个问题，
你引述他这个话，
我之前都是不知道的，
就我，本身我自己，
不太爱看画摄影画摄影，
也不太去了解摄影大师的一些东西，
但是我知道这个人，
对，我也知道养子，
但是你引述这个东西以后，
我就去真的去了解了一下，
包括我后来，
我也找到了养子，
真的去说过，
就是说他在说，
他说他那些日子里，
对，强迫我暴露在街头，
在众人好奇的目光下做出那些知识，
这就是一种霸道行为，
就是一种权力，
就是他在发号，
对他的妻子发号4令，
就是你要，
你要什么样的知识，
你比如你要展开你的手臂，
他其实是在，
并不把他当成一个，
单独的个体来对待，
所以其实养子，
他已经作为，
被设者，他已经在表示，
一种反抗了，
包括甚至后来，
养子和他其实也是离婚了嘛，
这个我也时候，
查到的资料，
所以,
所以我就想说，
就是,
摄影啊，就是，
当他拥有了，
记录啊，传播啊，定义他人的，
他真的就是一种，
天然的拥有了一种什么，
能力，或者说权力，
嗯,
所以其实，
你在,
你的引述把这些权力，
全部,
抛露的出来，
我觉得这个特别特别好，
其实我自己都觉得，
我不是完全的，
清白的，因为之前，
其实我跟他拍照的时候，
我们也不是说，
过程都非常和谐，
就是我们有时候也会吵架，
就是我印象很深的有一次嘛，
因为我之前是，
我是拍那个，
我有拍婚礼，
你还拍过婚礼，是商业的婚礼啊，
对,
然后，那段时间，
因为拍了很多婚礼嘛，
然后我就是，
在引导人摆动作的时候，
我的那些画术都非常的，
商业化，
就是那画术非常的，
你说你的脸稍微转一点点，
或者怎么样的手摆到那个位置啊，
然后，后面有一次，
我就是给马尺拍照的时候，
我就是很，
条件反射的用了那一套画术，
对,
然后我的画术就是，
让他要怎么怎么摆，
然后他当时就，
他就有点不开心了，
他就说，他就觉得，
因为这样的话，
就是去引导他摆什么姿势啊，
什么的，他就，
他就觉得很不舒服，
他觉得我不是他的女朋友了，
他觉得我们两个，
好像是一个客人，
还是一个客人跟一个婚礼，
正一式的那种感觉，
然后我们当时那个拍摄，
就直接终止了，
因为我们就开始吵了起来，
然后这件事情，
我印象非常深刻，
我当时就觉得，
这就是一种暴力吧，
我觉得，
但是这种暴力，
对，但是这种暴力，
在你早期的时候，
你是不自知的，
这个我觉得，
这才是最可怕的一个点，
就是很多时候，
当我们拿起相机，
拿起相机以后，
我们拥有了主动权，
或者说我们拥有了，
我们掌握了这些权力，
所以我们就会把它，
所谓的，
就是说，
并不当成一个，
完全的个体来看待了，
我们只是把它当成一个，
对象,
或者是一个产品来对待，
我跟你说，
这种,
就是典型的，
叫做,
典型的摄影暴力，
真的,
就很多人不自知，
这种暴力，
嗯,
而且这种暴力，
最多发生在哪里，
就是亲人关系里面，
嗯,
特别是，
养子，包括养子拍，
包括生来长久拍养子，
它就是，越亲密，
这种暴力越隐蔽，
你像你最早拍那个婚礼，
它其实，
这种反而是，
没那么隐蔽的，
因为它是直接的，
就是我被拍的这个新娘，
她是有诉求的，
她觉得你这样，
直接我可以让我更美，
对，她就，就可以了，
但是你亲密关系，
她没有选择的权利，
你就只能，
你就只能处在那里，或者说，
你在你任何，
所以很多时候，
呃,
这样的照片是会引起很多的，
讨论的，比如我们，
其实前两年就，好像就是24年左右吧，
就是,
有一个国内的事，
我不知道你当时知不知道这个事，
信带,
对对对，
对,
这就是一个典型的例子嘛，
对，她其实，
她就是处在这样的暴力中嘛，
嗯,
所以真的，很多时候，
我们去，
理解,
创作，或者说，我们现在创作的过程中，
并不意味着，
我们一定要，
放弃，就是说，
就是你被创作者，
就是要放弃她的身体，
就她其实，她有绝对的，
呃，选择权，
嗯，对，所以，
后来，就是那件事，
后来，就是也是让我，
会反思，就是，
如果在一个不太熟悉的环境下，
我还要坚持去拍摄的话，
是不是，
就是不应该这样的，
是呀,
就是，这件事情，
这件事情必须是，
呃，模特，它是必须是，
没有不舒服的那种感觉，
就是，我必须要在这样的，
条件下我才会想要去进行那个拍摄，
是的,
所以很多时候，
而且很特别，
特别是，我去年拍的，
那些照片，你问的一些题材嘛，
就比如说那个，
有一张是，
呃，手腕上有露，
疤痕的那一张，
因为那张它，
这个照片的手是它的，
嗯,
然后我当时去拍之前，
我就是有，
他能不能拍，
你说我，我说我可能还会发，
发，发出去，
我就是有问过他的，
然后他说，嗯，
他说OK，他接受，
然后我才会去拍，
就是他如果愿意展示他，
自己身体的这样一个部分，
他是同意的话，
我才可以说把他，
发到社交平台上，
对，我觉得，作为模特，
呃，这个同意，
可以拒绝，可以返回，
可以要求删除，
可以拒绝公开，
对，他一定有这个选择的权利，
嗯,
不然很多，
所谓的合作，
包括我后来跟你说那个，
荒木拍那个模特，
他其实就是这样的一个状态，
就是，他们，
本来是合作的，
但是其实这个模特，
那其实，
这个已经不是合作了，
这就是一种，
霸权嘛，
他直接就是，
默认了这个模特，
他需要牺牲这么多，
并没有把这个模特当成一个，
独立的个体来对待，
他的合作关系是不存在的，
还有就是，
我们前面说，
就是，为什么总喜欢，
还最亲近的人，
因为，就是为什么这些事，
总发生在亲近的人身边，
就是因为，
这种亲近的关系啊，
本身容易接近，
而且最容易忽视掉的就是边界嘛，
就是本身作为情侣，
他本身就没有边界，
然后这种没有边界的状态，
很容易让摄影生名乎，
以为我可以，
似乎记得，
嗯,对,
就这样的一个状态，
而且，这是一个非常高，
高发的状态，
就我们，你前面说，
你自己也不是绝对的清白，
就是我们任何一个，
不过我自己，我可能也，
也并不一定是绝对的清白，
就是很多时候我们在拍一个人的时候，
我们满脑子都在想着自己的表达，
但是没有想到对方，
他是一个什么样的心理，
他怎么样，
他是否可以接受这样的一个状态，
对吧,
他到底是在观看一个人，
还是在占有一个人，
这个,
所以其实你的，
你跟马驰的这个状态，
我觉得目前来说，
你所回答的都是
非常好的一个状态，
最起码你们处在一个相互。
创作,
因为他自己也拍照，
而且他，你跟他说一下，
他发的太少了，
就是他拍的非常棒，
而且你为什么当时是，
他给了你很多灵感，
让你开始创作，
我觉得是因为，
他的确有非常强的，
表达的状态，
这个,
对，我能感觉到，
对，这个非常非常难得，
所以,
让他多多更新，
就我不知道他，
为什么更新的频率那么低，
可能还，
他可能，
目前还没有说找到一个很舒适的，
用表达的，
那我能理解，
这个过程是一定要是需要，
时间的，或者说，
甚至他可能是某个契机，
就像你，你，你当时有个朋友，
介绍你的环境地，
这样的一个，就实际上是一个契机嘛，
对,
他会觉得自己拍的不好，
但是我有跟他说，他拍的很好，
对啊，所以，
所以我做环境地，
很多人都会说，啊，我拍的很差，
我说，你拍的很差，不是一个应该，
应该来这里发嘛，
你拍的很差，然后让别人意识到你的差，
让别人看到你的差，
或者说你在发的过程中，
看到别人的差，好，
那你就能意识到，反过来，
意识到自己的差嘛，对吧，
所以这个，真的，
一定要发，一定要发，
我这样，对，我这样要做发发，
我看一下评论者，
嗯,
好奇后面怎么解决呢，
就是,
关于模特怎么，怎么去拍模特，
这个怎么解决吗，
我觉得其实，
他并不一定是，需要怎么解决，
而是,
要警惕一点，就是说，
不是权力，
本身的问题，而是，
摄影师，
呃,
忘记了，自己拥有，
这样的权力的时候，
才最可怕，
嗯，对，就当你，
忘记了他了，你忽视了他，
其实你当时拍了婚礼以后，
再拍马尺，你就是忘记了，
对，你就是本能，
你就是觉得，我就应该这样拍，
哎，你脸，
我觉得你这边转过来，就很好看，
对吧,
对，你忘记了才是最可怕，
你只要记住，
你的权力，
你掌握了这样的权力，
那你在掌握这样的权力的时候，
你怎么跟对方去沟通，
怎么跟对方，
表达你最终想要拍的那个东西，
是不是对方说，
也能接受的，
这是一个非常，
非常有必要的事情，
就是当你忘记了，
你根本就没有意识的时候，
才是最可怕的，
但是如果你记得你的权力，
你就可以把这个事儿解决了，
因为你记住了，你就知道，
我该怎么跟对方沟通了，
嗯，而且那个杨子那个，
那个照片，
我觉得还有一个问题就是，
其实杨子他，
他都不知道，
为什么伤害长久，要那样去拍他，
因为我觉得，
被拍的人他，
他一定要知道就是，
我在干什么，
是，所以，
就是那件事之后嘛，
然后我都会很明确，
就是告诉他为什么要这样拍，
这个非常重要，
对，这个非常重要，
而且这种，
这种表达一定是和亲密。
关系,
就是你拍亲密关系，
或者拍家人，拍亲人的时候，
拍爱人的时候，
最需要的，
就是你反而拍陌生人的时候，
放得那么重，真的，
尤其是亲人的时候，
就是越容易，
就我们越觉得，
我们跟亲人那么亲密无间，
对吧，他都会理解，
这个最可怕的事，
就是他都理解我，
那我就，就可以忽视他的感受嘛，
这个才是最可怕的，
嗯,
我也是，我也有这种问题，
为了说我，我老婆会觉得，
这样拍不好看，对吧，
我就会强行说，
这样很好看，
对，这确实也是一个问题，
就是我们每个人都不是清白的，
但是我们每个人都可以，
去慢慢地意识到，
这个问题它存在着，
然后，你刚才说到羊子，
其实，好像我，
我当时查资料好像也看到了，
后来那个生爱长久不是因为，
脑损伤癱瘓了嘛，
好像还是羊子去照料他，
一直到去世，
然后我就觉得，
嗯，当初他们可能，
因为这样的一个事情，
就是生爱他那么的，
专注于摄影，
忽略了他的对，
他的配偶，他的另外一半的感受，
但是，这种亲情的关系，
这种亲密的关系，
他其实，也不是说，
他离婚了就会断掉的，
就是，那爱，
可能一直还是在的，
但是很多时候，这种，
在我们活着的时候，
或者说在我们，
急赋表达遇的时候，
是被忽视的，
当你已经，
快要跟这个世界，
白白的时候，
他可能，
依然愿意接纳你，愿意，
来照顾你，对吧，
我觉得这个，
是我觉得蛮感动的一个事情，
所以，所以我们，
会想到什么，
我们迷流之际之前呢，
我们在，正在，
创作的各位，
那怎么去看待，
这样的亲密关系，怎么样去，
在这个亲密关系里面，
去,
共同实现一种表达，
这个真的，
任众而道远，我觉得，
不是说，我们意识到，
就一定会做好，
他一定是，也有一个，
魔力的一个过程，
有这样的权力的时候，
就我们，太多的例子，
我们现在这个时代，
很多人就是因为，
他们根本不意识到自己有权力，
或者说他们觉得，
他们的权力是理所当然，
这个我就不详细说了，
现实就是这样，
每天,
每天处在这样的时代，
就是这样的一个现状，
所以,
但我们能反思，
有这样的觉悟，
或者说我们有这样的机会，
有这样的手段，
通过摄影区，
不断的，
回过头看自己，这个很重要，
好,那,
我们最后，
最后收头尾吧，
我底下做了很多笔记，
好多我感觉，
都聊不完了，
我扯得太多了，
那也快了，
五分之四了，
快了，快了，
我们聊到最后吧，
你当时，
不是说，
没想到我会用这种方式来。
说你的名字，
你当时怎么想？
我觉得很明显，
因为我自己有看过你。
别的那个采访，
一般要问名字的时候，
会再开头问吗？
这个问题之后，
很适合放在最后一个问题问，
有一种，
好像到那个电影的大结局了，
要收尾了，
我为什么会这么想，
因为,
相对受过教育，
或者大部分人都知道，
去罗马，
条条大路，
通罗马这个理念，
但是,
我们就认知，
好像罗马是什么，
我们根本不知道，
但其实罗马当时是一个，
其实是一个军事，
或者说一个商业的，
一个集合，
就所有人都去那边通商，
因为他那里繁荣，
所以,
其实很多人可能并不意识到，
条条大路通罗马，
合心通罗马，
到底是干嘛，
我看到你这个名字，
我说去罗马，
那我们摄影真正去到罗马，
是去什么呢，
我们摄影最终追求的是什么，
对吧,
所以他就顺理成章，
就会引述到这个方向，
我觉得就是非常好的一个契合点，
对，很妙，
没有,
就是小心机，
小心机，
所以最后我也想问，
这个问题好，
没关系，
你可以慢慢想，
我想说我最想被别人记住我的什么，
对,
就是你的风格，
或者说你的照片，
只是你的照片，
还是说你这个人的，
人的一种
魅力，或者什么，
你可以想一想，
那应该还是，
我的照片吧，
我可以，
可以,
电子永生，在这个互联网上，
哇,
这必须啊，
一定是电子永生，
就是,
哪怕我们，
价格稀趣，好像，
互联网上还有这些照片存在，
对,
因为我确实是把我的很多东西，
都放在我的图像上，
是，能看得出来，
表达了非常多的你的，
心理状态，
你的一个，
现实的一个，
对现实的一个观察嘛，
我还想问一下，
就是说，你最后，
提到了，
你不知道去罗马意味着什么，
你觉得他可能是爱，
或者也可能是真，
或者说，
有些东西会在这个，
探索的路上慢慢的，
显现嘛，对吧，
那你觉得，
自己会变成一个，
拥有爱，
或者说，无限，
真诚，自由的人吗，
你会，你会通过摄影，
变成这样的人吗，
因为你最终要追求的这个东西，
就是这个，
就如果你真的有一天，
到了属于自己的罗马，
就是你去了那个地方，
你真正找到了答案，
那你觉得你会变成一个，
这样子的人吗，
我相信我会吧，
那一定啊，
就是如果我们不相信，
我们去追求这个东西干嘛呢，对吧，
对,
我感觉我现在，就是，
嗯，有点像，
无头蒼蠅，
我不知道我应该往那边飞，
然后，好像就是，
只是一直在离开的感觉，
不知道我到底会到，
到达哪个地方，
因为我是今年，
刚从江州，
离开江州，然后来到了宁波，
但是其实我，
我当时想的也只是，
要离开江州，
就是到达那个目的，好像，
我没有想太多到底要去哪，
就是，只是因为我之前在宁波待过，
然后我就想说来宁波吧，
然后就来到这边，
但是,
他其实会不会说，就是说，
就是有一天我们会发现，
人生,
好像，并没有真正所谓的到达，
就是,
对吧，他可能，
或者说你到达了，你都会失望，
他目的地，并不是，
你想一想的那个样子，对吧，
对，他可能，
是,
我觉得人可能，
人这一生都是，
路上,
这并不一定是，
要到达，
然后我会想到，
你跟马池，
就是，又回到了，
我们最开始的问题上面，
就是，你从最早，
遇到马池，你从他身上，
集取到的那些力量，
或者说那些，
那些，那些，
理想，那些感受，
呃,
你们不断的了解对方，
然后,
最终，好像说，
你在和他，
共同的，
这样的一个，
呃，相互，
牟利的一个状态，
他，其实本身是不是，
已经是，
罗马，或者说，
他已经达到了，
那样的一个状态，
这是不是一个，非常，
对，我可能已经到罗马，
但是我可能就是看不到，
对，对，对，
我觉得，是不是，就是说，
罗马就是马池，
当时起这个名字，
就是因为，为了有一个，
字要跟我，
想排排用，
那为什么叫马池呢？
因为,
因为他之前的网民叫，
牙疼，他之前网民叫，
死于牙疼，因为他经常牙疼，
然后后面我就，
我就跟他说，
这个名字好不吉利啊，
我密称一下吧，
要不就给他换个名字，
不要起这个名字，
然后你就想，
就想到了马池，
因为他有一个马，
然后有一个池，
因为那个马池线嘛，
有一种植物叫，
马池线，
所以他就取名叫，
所以啊，所以我在想，
呃，去罗马，
是不是你已经到了，
就是，马池是不是，
就是罗马，
因为我觉得，人，
我还回到这个，
我最早问马池的时候，
我会说妙思这个，这个词啊，
因为我觉得，妙思不是一个坏词，
就他，因为他最早的含义，
他并不是坏词，
他甚至就是我们，
对，他就是我们追求的，
想要去到罗马，
想要追求的那个真和爱的东西，
的一个，
最早的一个解释，
所以其实，
你遇到马池，
你们相互陪伴了，
也满一好几年，对吧，
然后你们在这几年，
又相互的产生了一种，
同时喜欢拍照，
同时，相互
去创作一些东西，
我觉得这个才是，
真正,
罗马那个地方，
已经有了的东西，
所以真正，你已经到哪了罗马，就，
对,
所以我选了那首歌，
那首歌，
就是,
Love is everywhere,。
是啊，所以啊，
所以就，
是不是，
很完美的收尾，
对你,
很有积蓄感，
是啊，我就觉得，
因为他其实又回到了我，
第一次看到你拍马池的那些照片，
就是他本身，
他也给我传递了，
你可能想要说，
你追求的那个真，
那个爱，那个状态，
就是因为我看到那些照片的时候，
我会激发我内心的那种，
爱的表达，
或者说我觉得，
他呈现了一种很真的状态，
或者说很，
很不和当下这个世界，
不一样的一个状态，
他可能是有瑕疵的，
他可能是有，
是有不一样的一个表达，
有像一个，
烂掉的苹果，
我并不觉得，
烂掉的苹果就是不好的，
对吧,
好嘞，那我们今天，
算是,
哎，聊了一个半小时，
也算是我们这个，
环新的人的专访的一个，
常规的一个时间，
常规的时间，
你觉得聊的少了吗？
我以为会聊两三个小时，
两三个小时是我们那个。
电台，因为会联系好几个作者，
所以会联系比较长，
然后单个作者其实，
90分钟已经非常长了，
就如果剪刀，剪刀，
什么波刻，都是非常长的，
嗯,
你还有什么想说，可以继续啊，
我们可以继续，
你还有什么想要表达的？
我觉得，
差不多了，
或者你有什么想问的，
因为我可能我确实，
我输出了一点多，
但是我的这些输出，
也是基于你的，
就是一定是你所，
传递给我的东西，
我觉得挺好的，
因为我还挺被动的，
因为我感觉，
我有时候我的表达，
是有点跟不上我闹的一想的，
然后,
我觉得你今天就是，
帮我说出了很多我也很想说的东西，
哎呀哎呀，过于了过于了，
真的有的时候，
因为我可能我们俩，
我们俩是有一个身份上的一个，
一个差别的，
因为我需要控场嘛，
他比如冲营啊，
或者说我会考虑东西更多一点，
但是,
我可以承诺的事，
我所有发出的问题，
都是我自己真切的感受到的，
这个是毋庸置疑的，
我感受不到我也不可能问出来，
我也不可能表达出来，
对,
所以,
你有没有想问我的，
或者说都可以再聊，没关系，
不用担心时间，
我就很想感谢你，
因为你当时
给我的那个采访稿，
就是我感觉，
我感觉你是真的有感受到。
我想表达的东西，
我真的是非常，
非常感动，
因为你给我的那十个问题，
我当时就是看了好久，
我在想，我要死的一万岁，
太会出问题了吧，
我当时一直在说，
就是,
那是所有人的能力，
就是当你真正正正的去。
看一个人的内容的时候，
你一定会有很多想法出来的，
只不过，
很多人都停在表面，
比如我们在小红树树刷土，
我们在环境地刷土，
只是在刷那个流，
然后刷过去，
它停不下来，
那我为什么会有这些问题出来，
是因为我愿意停下来，
我也想停下来，
这些东西因素在了，
任何人都可以停下来，
去感受一个人的，
所以环境地，
它其实就是希望，
能够提供这样的一个场域，
能让很多人愿意慢下来，
多看一两眼，
因为我们活在这个世界，
太快了，
包括我们其实时间都在变快，
你会发觉，
现在的时间，
根本不是以前的那个时间了，
就是,
我每周做那个
那个环境封面，
我就感觉，我昨天刚做了，
今天又要投票了，
就是一直处在这样的一个状态，
觉得时间过得太快了，
所以，在这么快的时间下面，
我们能尽量的，
去详细地感受一个人，
感受一些作品，
这已经是非常难得的事情，
要珍惜，
对，大家还有什么问题，
然后,
你也可以想想，还有什么问题，
然后，我们再，
几分钟，两分钟吧，
你像这个深爱拍这个羊子，
我最早的时候，
看到的时候，
我相信大部分人看到的时候，
都会觉得，哇，真美好，
对吧?
对，这种状态多么美好，
怎么会有，就是一个摄影师，
他对他的妻子，
怎么去观察，每天这么，
但是,
谁又能知道这个羊子，
他自己心里面是怎么想，
谁关心的，
甚至没人关心的吧，
就是,
只是在觉得，
这是一种，
摄影上的一种巧言意思，
是的,
所以，就是很多时候，
一定要，
抛开表面，看本质，
当然，我们并不一定说，
能把本质，
挖到多少的程度啊，
但是，我们一定要有这种，
愿意去，
去了解的这样的一个，
一个愿景，或者说，动力，
好,
但是我还是很喜欢上赖装酒的，
哦，那，对，那不用自疑，
不用自疑，就是，
不用自疑，
对，不用自疑，他确实拍的好，
然后，他拍那个鸭真的是，
在日本，都是属于，
前三名的，或者是前二名的，
真的是非常，
但是他压的感受，我们就不用考虑了，
呵呵,
但是,
依然,
就是，没办法，
去否定他的才华，或者说，
他的,
表达欲，对，这个东西，
是无用自疑的，
但很多时候，
我们需要去，
不是一股脑的觉得，
好啊，好啊，好啊，对，
他需要带一些反思，或者带一些诗辩，
甚至带一些怀疑，
但这种怀疑，并不是一定，
我们就否认了他嘛，对吧，不可能否认他，
他的地位，
不可能被否认，
OK,那,
评论就没有人评论了，那，
你还有什么想说的嘛，
没事，就慢慢了，
应该都，我都说完了，应该，
好呀，好呀，反正没关系，
后面就用，
就用照片说，
然后，照片说话，对，
让马子也用照片说，
他，他有在你身边，
他有在你身边，
他在房间里有，
但我就跟他说，
好嘞，好嘞，
你告诉他，我很欣赏他的照片，
我也，不，我，我，
好像说，对对对，很喜欢他的拍的，
然后当然也很喜欢他，
透露出来的那种气质，
对，然后，
祝你们，
一切都，
平顺,
然后,
对，双方都，
都可以，
享受创作的嘛，享受这个过程，
嗯,
好嘞，那今晚就这样，
最好的祝福，
那我们就，
欢迎订阶吧，后面，
好,
拜拜，晚安晚安，
晚安晚安，